Jurassic Park the movie that
simultaneously made kids love dinosaurs
and then suddenly be terrified of them
Spielberg my friend you are a master
guys real quick before I talk about
Jurassic Park I just want to let you
know that pretty soon I'm actually going
to be visiting my buddy John the flick
pick you guys know him and I just wanna
let you know that we're gonna be doing
some videos together and some of them
might be on his vlog channel his John
Flixter Channel great channel if you
haven't checked it out he's got a little
video here for you really quick I just
want to show it to you because I'm going
to be going over to his house when it
gets a little bit warmer we're gonna
maybe make some video game reviews
together we're going to do some of that
kind of stuff together and I hope you
guys subscribe to him and check him out
there's an annotation there for you to
do that
enjoy now suppose to be a blurry
concoction spitting in my face that
makes me feel like I'm on a bad acid
trip and some big guy came by punch me
in the face two times my eyes are
swollen up I'm bleeding out of my
orifice now let's talk about Jurassic
Park 3d Jurassic Park 3d opens on April
5th now from what I hear there is an
embargo on this film despite the fact
that I was not told about this I'm going
to be very careful because I'm not
really supposed to talk in depth about
the 3d of this movie so I can obviously
review a 20 year old movie whenever I
want
but don't worry I'll let you know if
it's worth your while later on in the
review Jurassic Park is a movie that I
grew up with and it meant a lot to me as
a kid it's of course directed by Steven
Spielberg it stars sam neill laura dern
jeff goldblum richard attenborough wayne
night or Newman from Seinfeld and even
samuel l.jackson in one of his earliest
roles before pulp fiction access main
program access main security hold onto
your butts of course you know the plot
of this movie two paleontologists are
invited to be kind of the first test run
of this new park with genetically
engineered dinosaurs that they were able
to clone from frog DNA and old
mosquitoes that had drank the blood of
dinosaurs that were caught in SAP they
removed those mosquitoes from the amber
that they found underground they were
able to use that DNA to clone dinosaurs
and for that reason this movie became
more than just a monster Island movie
like they used to do in the old days
some b-movie they actually gave some
interesting scientific reasons for why
the dinosaurs were there and so for that
reason this movie was not just some fun
blockbuster and a fun ride you could go
on it was actually some legitimate stuff
you could actually think about go
that's interesting that wouldn't happen
but that's awesome
obviously a lot of that is due to the
book by Michael Crichton which is a
really great read by the way I've had
this for a long time I had look at look
at this thing
look at it from a visual effects
standpoint this movie was absolutely
groundbreaking and seeing this film 20
years later there are a few shots in the
movie where you can tell yeah that CGI
is dated but for 95 percent of the time
the CGI in this movie still is
astounding it is fantastic the realism
they were able to create with these
dinosaurs in fact I recently watched
Jurassic Park 3 again which came out in
2001 the CGI in that film does not hold
up as well as the movie from 1993 isn't
that amazing
also this film used an incredible amount
of realistic props in fact I would say
there's actually more realistic prop
dinosaurs than there was actual CGI and
that is a credit to Spielberg wanting to
do it that way and all of the creature
and prop designers who work on this film
because there was some seriously
astounding work in this movie from just
a visual and technical aspect this film
is near flawless but David keps
adaptation also was great featuring
fantastic characters each one of the
characters wasn't just somebody who
could run away from dinosaurs each one
of them had an interesting thing about
them that made them human right down to
the children in the movie which oculus
lis are not annoying they actually had a
huge part to this film usually kids and
movies suck at acting and are annoying
in general but these kids were good
Spielberg is a master at working with
children in film but they served a
purpose from the movie as well because
Allen grants character played very well
by Sam Neill has this thing where he
just he doesn't know about kids you see
this great opening scene where he taunts
this kid he's like that doesn't look
very scary more like a 6-foot turkey he
slashes at you with this here or here
maybe across the belly spilling your
intestines I love that scene that scene
is priceless Laura Dern's character
isn't just some damsel in distress she's
actually a strong female role she's
really great in the film and she works
well she has good chemistry with Sam
Neill you believe their relationship
Jeff Goldblum in this movie is one of
the most entertaining characters of the
90s flat-out the character of Ian
Malcolm is so much fun but he's not
some wacky goofy sidekick guy who pops
jokes never once in a while he's
actually a legitimate Lee well written
character has a great brain in that head
of his
and he's the guy who kind of forced
shadows what's gonna happen he's like
look I don't know if you should do this
I don't know I'm Jeff Goldblum ah well
well there it is yes but your scientists
were so preoccupied if they could they
didn't stop to think if they should what
you call discovery I call the rape of
the natural world and especially Richard
Attenborough as Hammond the creator of
this thing you really feel as the movie
progresses you get to see so much about
his character the layers he has why he
wanted to make a park like this and why
it's hurting him so much that it's not
working out each one of these characters
in this movie is important but they're
not just fun people
they're likable characters that actually
seem like real people who have good
backgrounds and they all relate to the
story in very good ways Spielberg adds
something to every single shot the
certain shots in this movie that keep
going on he composes so many things in
them now if you haven't seen Jurassic
Park I implore you to please that's
fantastic but if you haven't seen it I'm
about to spoil it one of the best jump
scares in history because this film has
one of the best jump scares in history
when I saw this film in theaters I knew
it was coming now a friend of mine was
sitting next to me hadn't seen it in a
long time and I was looking and when
that head popped through he left out of
his seat and he is like in his 40s okay
he just left he was like oh my god it
was great because it's one of the most
unexpected jump scares ever Spielberg
doesn't do any of those dumb cliches
like oh the meter closed and there's a
dinosaur in the mirror or oh the sump
pump out of trash no it's just a cat he
knows how to create legitimate tension
in this film and it's not just the
tension in the last half of this film
that is so fun and impressive it's the
sustained wonderment throughout the
entire first half
Spielberg creates one of the most
jaw-dropping scenes in history the first
time these guys see the Brachiosaurus
now half of that is due to John Williams
fantastic theme da da da
da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da
I couldn't stop I have to say that that
music is fantastic I like it more than
jaws I like it more than Superman I
might even like it more than Star Wars I
don't know
I love his themes for this film at scene
where they first see the Brachiosaurus
and Sam Neill is like moving in herds
they do and John blames music and
everything it's just so great I just
they don't make movies like this anymore
they just don't they don't make movies
like this anymore I want to see more
movies where there's actually a lot of
silence in the scene where a character
actually stares at something for a while
and you get that feeling of awe and the
music sweeps you into the movie movies
are just missing that amazement that ah
that wonderment everything is so quick
cut edited nowadays everything is so
packaged and ready to be delivered in
the theaters so an audience can sit
there or not be bored I was watching
this film and I was realizing this movie
actually takes its time to tell its
story you know it doesn't just open oh
and just throw dinosaurs at the screen
uh like it actually takes time to get
you into the characters to make you
understand the story and then it all
hits the fan dinosaurs are everywhere
and is absolutely riveting now really
quickly about the 3d as I said because
of a stupid studio embargo for some
reason I'm not allowed to talk in depth
about the 3d I can tell you that it is
great it is the best post converted 3d I
have seen since Titanic 3d I loved it
loved it loved it I'll never look at the
movie the same way Jurassic Park is one
of my all-time favorite films that's one
of the best movies that came out in the
90s in my opinion of course I'm going to
give Jurassic Park and a plus so guys do
you plan on seeing Jurassic Park when
it's rereleased are you gonna try to see
a 2d showing of it are you gonna go for
the 3d let me know and also let me know
how you feel about the movie in general
thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck my next